An operating system has to feel external events. For example, external
interrupts that may come in when a process is executing. Or, the process
itself may incur some exceptions such as a page
fault. Or it may make system calls. All of these are events that needs to be
fielded by the operating system and SPIN has
to support such external events. And SPIN supports such external events
using an event based communication model. Services can register
what are called event handlers with the SPIN event dispatcher, and SPIN
supports several types of mapping. It support a one
to one mapping between an event and a handler.
It also support one to many mapping between an event and the handlers. And it
also supports many to one mapping, many events
being mapped to the same handler. And let's
look at concrete examples to illustrate the power
of this mapping and how it might help
in building system services. And what this picture
is showing you is a typical protocol stack.
And you may have several different interfaces available on
your machine. And therefore, a network packet may arrive
through one of several interfaces. Let's say you have
an Ethernet interface and you have an ATM interface.
A network packet may arrive on the Ethernet port
or an ATM port. Those are events, and both
of those may be IP packets, in which case
there is an IP handler that needs to see
the events. And so, here is an example of many events mapping to the same
handler. Ethernet packet arrival is an event, ATM
packet arrival is an event, different events but
they map the same handler, which is the
IP handler. That's an example of many-to-one mapping.
The processing of the packet by this IP
handler results in an IP packet arrival event.
And there will be several clients of the
IP layer of the protocol stack. There will be
UDP transport, there will be TCP transport, there will
be an ICMP layer. And they are all sitting
on top of this IP network layer. So when
an IP packet arrival event is figured by this
handler, there are multiple clients for that, and this
is an example of a one to many mapping,
one event, to multiple handlers, that need
to get triggered. And the SPIN dispatcher allows
any number of handlers to be registered as
handling a particular event type. And when that
even type is reached, then all the
handlers associated with that event type will get
scheduled by the SPIN dispatcher. The order in
which they get scheduled is not something that
the designer can count on, because SPIN has
freedom in the ordering which these event handlers
may get scheduled when a particular event arise.
But all the handlers that are associated with an
event will get triggered when that event is
released. That's an example of one to many mapping.
And finally, here is an example of a one to one mapping. If it's an ICMP packet,
the ICMP handler processes the IP packet, and
if it is an ICMP packet, then it raises
an event than an ICMP packet has arrived,
and maybe there is only one client for that
particular event, and that may be the ping program, so that's one, two on
mapping. Even handlers may also be specified with guards of
finer grain handler execution. For example, this handler could specify
that only when IP packets arrive it should be executed. So that's a guard that
the IP packet handler could specify so that even though different
kinds of packets may arrive on these interfaces, this handler will only get
triggered when the packet that arrived
on the different interfaces than IP packet.